قبل ايام من زلزال تركيا وتحديدا قبل
ثلاثه ايام توقع باحث هولندي حدوث وقوعه
وذكر الدول التي ستتاثر بالزلزال كتب
الخبير الهولندي والباحث في شؤون الزلازل
فرانك هوج كتب في تغريده ان زلزالا سيحدث
بقوه 7.5 في منطقه جنوب وسط تركيا والاردن
وسوريا ولبنان وحذر في تغريده اخرى من
الارتدادات التي تتبع الزلزال وشددا على
ضروره مراقبه النشاط الزلزال القوي
الاضافي في وسط تركيا والمناطق المجاوره
قائلا انها عاده ما تستمر لفتره من الوقت
بعد وقوع زلزال كبير على كل حال تغريده
فرانس كانت محطه تساؤلات الكثيرين خاصه
اهل الاختصاص في الجغرافيا البيئه
والزلازل حتى انه عاد واكد تغريدته مفتخرا
انه كان يعلم بالرغم من ان هناك اجماع لدى
الخبراء على صعوبه التنبؤ بالزلزال قبل
حدوثه
[موسيقى]
كيف يمكن التنبؤ بالزلازل قبل وقوعها هل
هناك دلالات اشارات معينه بالنسبه
للتنبؤات بالزلازل علميا لا يوجد وسيله
علميه حتى الان او اي جهاز
لتحديد موعد زمني لحدوث زلازل ولكن ممكن
يبقى في بعض التوقعات في شواهد يعني مثلا
في بعض الاماكن بيحدث فيها زلازل يوميا
اذا زاد هذا المعدل عن المتوسط ده بيبقى
زي اشاره ان ربما يحدث زلزال هنا برضو
نقول ربما يحدث زي الكبير والحقيقه يعني
احنا لا نلجا الى هذا يعني التنبؤ لان ده
ممكن يعمل
ذعر شديد تخيلوا لو احنا مثلا قلنا من
اسبوعين تلاته انها في زلزال ممكن يحصل
فيها هنعمل ايه للسكان في تركيا الزلزال
هيحصل فين في تركيا
مساحه كبيره للغايه عندنا الشرق للغرب
1500 كيلو الناس تروح فين هل في الشرق
الناس تروح الغرب ولا من تركيا كلها هنا
ده احنا تنبانا لهنا لازم لازم التنبؤ
يكون يعني محدد
بمنطقه وبزمن بحيث ان بالفعل يعني نقدر ان
احنا السكان من هذا المكان لكن مش ممكن
يخلص سكان دوله
ان الكلام يبقى كده على اطلاقه ايضا لما
نقول يعني لما نقول ان في زلزال هيحصل في
هذه المنطقه وان في دول مثلا تركيا وسوريا
والاردن اي زلزال هيحصل في تركيا هيؤثر
على هذه الدول يعني ما هي دي دي هذه هي
دول الجوار وبالتالي ليس بجديد ان احنا
نقول مين اللي هيتاثر
[موسيقى]